We've talked about how booleans take on the value of either true or false.
And so far we've been directly assigning that value.
Like with the code boolean b1 equals true and boolean b2 equals false.
But boolean values can also be calculated by doing tests like comparisons,
and these are called boolean expressions,
and expressions look something like this.
This expression, which checks if three is less than five,
is something we know is true.
Three is less than five.
And, in fact, this expression evaluates to the boolean value of true,
and we can assign that value to a boolean variable like before.
And let's name this one b3.
So here b1 and b3 are equal to the same value.
True. But b3 is assigned to the value of this comparison and not to true directly.
Then if we wrote this expression,
which checks if three is greater than five,
this would evaluate to the boolean value of false since three is not greater than five.
And then b2 and b4 will have the same value.
There are a number of ways that we can compare
numbers or variables that will evaluate to true or false.
In addition to these less than and greater than expressions,
we can also have less than or equal to and greater than or equal to.
And let's use these in examples too.
We could compare two numbers again like to test if seven is less than or equal to six.
And since seven is greater than six then this expression is not true,
it evaluates to false.
And instead of using numbers,
we can use variables in these comparisons too.
Like say we have declared an integer variable named
X and initialized it to 10 before starting these comparisons.
We can then compare that variable to another number or variable,
like this expression which tests,
"Is X greater than or equal to 10?"
Java will see this and say X is 10.
So, yes, it's equal to 10 and the expression is true.
And if we want to only test for equality,
we use double equal signs so we can test something like if
X is equal to 9 and since 10 is not equal to 9,
this expression will evaluate to false.
And let's look at this equality check in detail.
In Java, the double equal sign tests for equality and is not to be
mistaken with the single equal sign which in Java is a variable assignment.
So when we write X equals equals
nine this expression is the equivalent of the boolean value false,
and our variable X will still be equal to 10.
But if we said X equals nine with one equals,
this would change the value of X from 10 to 9,
and no boolean value will be calculated.
So remember to use double equals signs to check for equality.
And to check if two values are not equal,
we use exclamation point equals,
where this exclamation point means not.
So X not equal to 9 will evaluate to true because 10 is not equal to 9.
It's the opposite of the previous equality check.
And because all these types of expressions evaluate to true or false,
they are often used as test conditions in decision making if statements.
But before we get to using these for decision making,
let's get more practice evaluating these expressions.